a common house biter has eight eyes
if a spider is looking at you
with two it's two front eyes and three
of its other eyes
and three of its other eyes what
fraction of its eyes are looking at you
and just to show that we're not making
this stuff up this is actually pictures
of spiders and you see in every one of
these pictures they have eight eyes even
this one the other eyes right over here
one two three four five six
seven eight i never even realized this
is actually quite quite creepy but
anyway let's actually focus on the
problem so it's looking at you at two of
its front eyes two of its two of its
eight eyes so the two front eyes
represent what fraction of the eyes well
it represents two of the eight
two of the eight eyes you could look at
it right over here you have eight eyes
maybe the two front eyes it's one and
two of the eight and it says it's also
looking at us with three of its other
eyes so it's also looking at us with
three
of the eight eyes
and so you could imagine that might be
that one that one and that one so this
is really about adding fractions this is
about adding 2 8 of something to 3 8 of
something so what fraction of its eyes
are looking at us
are looking at us well it's still going
to be a fraction of 8 it's going to be
still out of 8 2 plus 3
2 plus 3 over 8 2
plus 3
over 8
which is just going to be equal to
5 8 of the eyes 5 out of the 8 eyes are
looking at us and we see it right over
here 1 2 3 4 5 5 of the total of eight
eyes are looking at us in a fairly
creepy way